prime minister if someone was to come
and tell you that they'd been raped
would you as prime minister be able to
look them in the face
and say to them that there's a high
chance of justice being done
i want everybody to have that confidence
beth and at the moment i've got to tell
you that the answer to that is no i
don't think people do have enough
confidence in the criminal justice
system
to
deal with
that accusation uh those reports fast
enough and i don't think people have a
feeling that the police are handling
these issues fast enough either and that
is certainly that's
led to this feeling of of fury of
frustration uh betrayal on on the part
of millions of people
most of them women about about what's
happening now
the i i can point to
to figures showing that appalling
murders such as the murder of sarah
everardo are in fact
very rare and and and and and not
increasing in the in the way
but it's the that's right it's now that
feeling
is i think
caused by
uh frustration at the level of
successful prosecution your justice
secretary said that he was deeply
ashamed by the government's record are
you deeply ashamed
i certainly am not
happy with the way the things have been
going and i think that there are a lot
of of causes i think the police do a
wonderful job i don't i don't want to
it's very important you know i think
hundreds of thousands of police officers
men and women uh will be absolutely
sickened by what they're seeing because
they know that i know how hard they work
and how much they care about
what they're doing and they they might
be angry as well about cuts that made it
harder
for them to do their job well
what they've actually got is more police
out on the street and uh
uh we've recruited
we've know we've recruited you don't
agree 23
might have led to some of these you've
got 10 000 more of the 20 000 that we
promised and uh yes i i want to see more
police out on the streets and yes we're
investing in uh in things that make
streets safer but i think the issue
beth is is very it is it's the many
sides to it and
what i think is driving people wild with
with frustration
is the the length of time it takes and
that's you know that's that's
on sunday i asked you about that and you
said the cps are not dealing with
complaints fast enough or taking them
seriously enough but if we look at the
cts it's not just the cpsps spending
it's foul cuts of 28 percent
in real time no no let me finish between
2010 to 2019.
so the cuts make it more difficult to
prosecute and you can
you have to acknowledge don't you but
actually this is partly on
government cuts could be driving down
rape prosecutions after the criminal
justice system and this is a quote from
them was close to breaking point because
of cuts i know you're changing things we
are putting more prosecutors we are
putting many more prosecutors in and
have done but did you acknowledge that
that was part of the issue the issue is
i don't think it's always and everywhere
a question of more public money oh
because
robert buckland though
your former justice secretary he did say
budget cuts were partly to blame when he
published the rate review he said like
all parts of public service big choices
were made in the last decade because of
the position we all face economically i
think that's self evidently the case is
he wrong but that
and we're putting more and we're putting
more people in and we have done for for
a while now i think the phenomenon today
is is not just a question of money
and though we are putting more money
what i'd like you to do is acknowledge
okay you can change it but i'd like you
to acknowledge that the cps and the
justice department have faced cuts and
it's not just about the cps i think
police it's also on the government i
think i understand that you want to
blame the government for not spending
enough money
i think that's but i think that's what
you said but what we said
i said acknowledge your partner and so
what we're doing is and i certainly
acknowledge
my
responsibility for all of this but what
we're doing is putting more uh more
prosecutors into the cps but we also
need to fix beth is the way the the
whole thing works and so you need
tougher sentences which we've brought in
to act as a proper deterrent to people
but the the issues that we have are
complex questions of evidence and the
defense being able to by under
disclosure to access stuff from
victims mobile phones which is
incredibly distressing and which is
causing a great deal of delay and is
causing a great deal of victim attrition
prosperity execution rates and that is
the problem and that is what we need to
fix and what i've said to what i've said
the lowest on record and that's because
there's some 109 prosecutors and i've
been 55 000. 696 years and i'm totally
fed up with it and and the and the and
what's happened is that there are more
people coming forward more women
and it's almost of course always uh
almost invariably women coming forward
with accusations uh and that's in if
there's one sense in which that's a good
thing because it means that more people
have the confidence to come forward and
where and and the tolerance for this is
declining but what you've also got to
have is a contraction of that period
that the nightmarish period between
reporting it and the disposal and the
and the
the the the sentencing i guess and that
is taking far far too long i mean and
and and so so the re so the reasons for
that are those complicate those
evidential issues that i've raised we've
got to fix that we've got to have much
simpler protocols so that not everything
on a woman's phone uh can be disclosed
and we've got to we've got to simplify
things and and make sure that the the
perpetrators of these crimes women
invariably men get the
get the punishment
before we do that uh
just in terms of
the rape review and targeted conviction
rates you have set a target for your
government to increase back to 2016
levels that's
5190 prosecutions uh that's
2991 convictions by 2024. will you make
that as prime minister your personal
responsibility if we come back here in
two years time i care deeply about this
this is but you will you make that your
puzzle because you've made a department
for levelling up i will do so
i will do everything i will do
everything i can to to deliver that it's
going to be incredibly tough partly
because of the evidential problems so
you're not sure you can hit the team we
will do everything that we can we're
throwing everything at this i keep i
have regular meetings with the criminal
of the crime and justice task force we
get all the departments together things
are actually starting to improve and you
are seeing some signs of acceleration uh
in these cases uh but i want to see much
much more and to answer your you know
get back to your first question do i
want people to feel confident in the
streets yes i do beth and by the way i
do think people should feel would you
like to just apologize to women over
this i think the way that robert buckley
i think that the i think that certainly
on behalf of
government overall i think that this is
something where we where we have
government the whole system has not done
well enough
i i said it if you look back i said it
was as soon as i got into it it was one
of the first things i said in prime
minister's question times uh present
time when i was elected i'm going to run
on because i need to talk about the
economy and i spent a lot of time on
that because i think it's very important
for all the women and men watching
our channel just like just on the cost
of living and wages inflation running
over three percent heading towards four
percent the bank of england might push
up interest rates are you relaxed about
that look the the the the bank of
england will must make its own uh
decisions but what i think is that the
uh the uk economy is part of a a global
economic system that is coming back to
life i know very worried about inflation
and uh and and i'm very encouraged are
you worried about that i'm very
encouraged by the growth are you what
i'm seeing i i understand are you
worried about inflation people have been
people have been worrying about
inflation for a very long time uh i'm
looking at robust economic growth uh and
and by the way those fears have been
unfounded uh but i'm looking at robust
economic growth i think that uh the
supply
systems that we have logistics uh the
supply chains we have are incredibly
clever and robust and
supply will will meet demand and that's
and you're seeing that uh now in the in
the the petrol four courts where
supplies is coming in there is a there
is a there is a problem of of demand as
you know very human thing and i
appreciate people's frustration on that
but they people need to
uh behave in the in the normal way and
as the
global economy recovers and as the uk
economy uh comes roaring back to life uh
you're gonna see brilliant businesses
brilliant people making sure that we
have the the supplies that we need and
if you're asking ask about christmas one
more question christmas will be
considered that is the other day
i've got one more question i've got one
more question national minimum wage you
talk about wanting to raise wages why
don't you lift the national minimum wage
you've got it in your power well that we
will we'll see what the we've we've
lifted the living wage already my record
amount um i'm proud to have introduced
the uh the living wage and uh as the
conservative government uh introduced it
uh let's see what the low pay commission
says but we're also we're also doing an
awful lot to help people on on low
incomes and what's happening now is that
people on on lower incomes are actually
seeing their wages rise faster than uh
people on on hiring i'm taking that as
you're not ruling out
you should you should wait and see what
rishi does but
we will do everything we can to look
after people in the months ahead thank
you thank you